show 109 percent by shading so just as a
bit of a review 109 109 percent if we
were to write it out would literally be
109 per cent percent which is the same
thing as 100 and which is the same thing
as 109 per per and I could write cent
again but that's getting old cent means
100 so it literally means 109 per
hundred per hundred if you had 100 per
hundred you're dealing with the whole
but now we're have more than a whole we
have 109 400 we can actually write this
as a ratio or as a fraction this is the
same thing as 109 per hundred it's the
same thing as 109 over a hundred so
let's shade that in so we have a whole
here so we could consider this square a
whole in the last video we counted
there's this is a 10 by 10 square it is
cut up into a hundred pieces so if we
want 109 of those 100 pieces what are we
talking about well that means we're
going to shade in all of the hundred
right over here let me do that in a new
color
so we'll shade in all of this we'll
shade in all of this right here that
would be if you just shaded that in that
would be hundred percent that would be a
hundred over a hundred or a hundred per
hundred or a hundred percent I hope I
think you're getting the meaning of all
of this here I just want you to just
memorize the stuff this really just
means a hundred out of 100 or a whole
and you can see that this is the whole
square that's 100 100 right there the
question is saying show us 109 percent
by shading so we have to we already did
100 per 100 but we need to do another 9
so let's shade it another 9 so we know
we have a 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 so this
piece right here you could almost view
that is well that is that is 9 percent
that is 9 percent of an entire square
this is a hundred percent of an entire
square if you consider this whole thing
Plus this blue area right over here you
are talking about 100
and 9% of this of one whole square
hopefully that made sense